let's bring us a breaking news now and
the former south african president jacob
zuma
has been found guilty of contempt of
court
and has been sentenced to 15 months in
jail
the country's top court issued the
ruling on tuesday that's after he
failed to appear before an inquiry
investigating corruption
during his time in office the commission
has been hearing allegations the wealthy
gupta family used its friendship with
zuma
to win government contracts and
influence policy
mr zuma is no ordinary litigant
he is the former president of the
republic of south africa
who continues to will significant
political influence
and in whom lies a great deal of power
to incite
others to similarly defy court orders
his actions and any consequences or lack
thereof
are being closely observed by the public
so if his conduct is met with impunity
he will do significant damage to the
rule of law
the unique political position that mr
zuma
enjoys as the former president
constitutes a further exceptional
feature of this matter that justifies
a punitive sexual sanction
well let's speak i see familia miller he
joins us from johannesburg
for me just extraordinary sentence
handed down there to the former
president
just explain to us what's happened
this certainly is shocking for many
south africans
uh depending on whether they support
jacob zuma or not
i think it's unprecedented either way
especially given some of the statements
the former president has made
in recent months um up to the stage the
former president had been compelled to
testify as a commission of inquiry into
corruption in south africa and as you've
mentioned
to do with his relationship with a
specific
family that appeared to have power in
terms of the appointment of ministers
and um and and and government decisions
that affected contracts
specifically and allegedly they
benefited uh significantly from
the uh these are these contracts the
commission is continuing
zuma however appeared once in a two-year
period the second time
he left that commission uh refusing to
testify
for a number of reasons and this is
below the is under commission
then applied to the high the
constitutional court
to judge make a judgment on whether or
not yuma had
defied the court and if he was in
contempt and this
certainly appears to be the finding of
the court and if we look at some of what
it said
uh the the constitutional court
legislator said
zuma is vexatious conduct reprehensible
it smacks his malice and his arguments
are bereft of supporting facts
the constitutional court image judgment
is clearly
uh quite angry with zuma's conduct and
this certainly is about the supremacy
of the rule of law especially given
the position that zuma has held and the
political influence that he continues to
hold
and so jacob zuma's heading to jail then
i mean this corruption inquiry i assume
is still ongoing but
the former president's heading to jail i
mean is he able to challenge this in any
way or is the next time we see him
going to be in some sort of orange
jumpsuit well that's
that's likely to be the scenario this is
the highest court
in the land the constitutional court and
it's an apex court and so
he's not able to challenge that ruling
and this is specifically why that ruling
is so astounding
given that this would be the first
former president
implicated in corruption and potentially
heading to jail
we would have to hear from the national
prosecuting authority
uh and and and about what happens next
specifically
but we do know that this judgment can't
be challenged and it can't be appealed
and tell us more just quickly for me to
about this
ongoing corruption inquiry
i mean how is that progressing is he
likely to
er is he likely to face if found guilty
of corruption
any additional penalties
i think that is what's very interesting
about this ruling today
this under commission of inquiry is
exactly that
it is um upheld
uh by uh by various laws in south africa
but it is it's an enquiry that doesn't
necessarily have the ability to
charge or try any of the people
appearing there
once the inquiry finishes um its work
that report will be put together and
recommendations put forward
to the national prosecuting authority to
then lay charges
and take these particular issues forward
so
many in sub-africa have criticized the
inquiry for being truthless
basically just being a forum where the
country's being aired and nothing else
given that the inquiry has now taken
zuma to the constitutional court and he
is very much facing jail time this is
the first time we see
a big move by the commission that has
been criticized significantly in the
past
and this would also be while he's going
he might go to jail for contempt
specifically and not corruption
this is a massive development south
africa's fight against corruption
okay for me to mellow there bring us the
latest out of south africa on that
breaking news story for me
for now thank you very much